(Man shouts)
Stay down.
♪♪
It's very interesting, a family
immigrating to Mexico rather
than in the other direction.
It's a novel concept.
If you do what he say, if you
cross the border you're gonna
die.
You and your kids are gonna die.
Neil Cross:
The more I like the characters
that I'm writing,
the more peril I want to expose
them to.
Neil Cross:
You wanna see what any given
character is gonna do
Neil Cross:
in a given situation.
You need to drink.
♪♪
You're no good to the kids if
you're dead in the desert.
♪♪
Justin Theroux:
This has been a really hard
shoot.
♪♪
There's one way of shooting a
show, which is on sound-stages
in Burbank.
Justin Theroux:
You want it to look like the
desert you
Justin Theroux:
drive a little bit out of LA.
This is wildly different.
Actually going to all these
different places and it's so
diverse.
Logan Polish:
It was just so exciting.
Justin Theroux:
We were kinda having the similar
experience
Justin Theroux:
as the Foxes themselves.
Which is it started in
California, shooting that, oh
that's lovely.
Justin Theroux:
Then we went to this border-town
in Mexicali
Justin Theroux:
to shoot some of the
desert episode.
Justin Theroux:
It has this enormous scope and
this enormous canvas.
You often have, often have
nightmares thinking about that
episode.
Melissa George:
We had a fantastic director that
just put us through Hell
Melissa George:
because that's what they were
going through and that's
Melissa George:
what they decided they would do
to us.
Melissa George:
So we would eat cactus fruit and
thirsty and sleeping in a bus.
♪♪
(Blowing on hands)
Man:
Don't do that.
♪♪
Moisture makes it worse.
They'd surround us in the
environment our characters are
in.
Gabriel Bateman:
I definitely think it kinda
bonded us as a group,
Gabriel Bateman:
and makes us seem more like
a family.
And when you're sweating, you're
really sweating. Ya know?
Justin Theroux:
When you're cold, you're really
cold.
Justin Theroux:
When you're hot, you're really
hot.
Justin Theroux:
Hopefully that translates in the
show itself.
♪♪